what's up everybody
so over the past weekend and over the
last few days we got our first look at
Mysterio and spider-man far from home
and not only that but we also got a
better look at spider-man stealth suit
we have some photos and videos to break
down but if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe like and comment below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so you can enter my giveaway
I'll be giving away a few copies of
Avengers and Infinity Ward some special
edition memorabilia and some special
collector's items so our first look at
Mysterio he looks pretty good and as you
can see here it's pretty comic accurate
so as we can see here in this photo
where he's kneeling down he's got the
sword of maroonish Cape that Mysterio
wears in the comics he's also got the
green suit that Mysterio wears and his
gloves and his boots are actually gold
so in some of the comics his gloves are
really just a different tint of green
than his suit is but in some comics you
can actually see him wearing golden
gloves as well so this isn't really much
of a change they just decided to go with
the more gold gloves and boots but if we
take a look at this other photo we see
him more face on and we can see that
there's some sort of technology to his
outfit this actually makes perfect sense
because Mysterio is actually a man named
Quentin Beck in the comics Quentin Beck
is actually a special-effects artist and
stuntman for Hollywood and he ends up
fighting spider-man with technology and
illusions so the fact that his suit has
some sort of technology to it makes
perfect sense and I also think it looks
really good in this video we have a
scene where him and spider-man are
facing off against each other as you can
see some of their surroundings are on
fire this is most likely caused by
Mysterio it was probably an attack on
some of the people that were there or an
attack on spider-man himself in the
scene we also get the best look that
we've gotten so far at spider-man
stealth suit people were wondering
whether spider-man made the stealth suit
himself or whether somebody gave it to
him but as you can see it looks pretty
advanced which most likely means that
somebody else gave it to him there's
also a logo on the upper left part of it
that looks a lot
like the shield logo and coincidentally
in this video three black cars pull up
most likely shield especially since we
already know that Nick Fury a Maria Hill
are going to be in the movie so it looks
like spider-man will be working with
shield in some way shape or form in
spider-man far from home
so that's it for the first look at
Mysterio and the new look at spider-man
stealth suit let me know your thoughts
on this first look at Mysterio don't
forget to subscribe like and comment
below to enter the giveaway and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]